air france fait le bilan pour 78
résultat positif après ceux des années
précédentes qui étaient plutôt
désastreux le président d'air france
monsieur giraudet estime pourtant que la
compagnie nationale doit faire des
efforts pendant plusieurs années encore
inventer de 10 et bleu comme ça
l'attractivité de vos passages nous
avons dépassé 10 millions de passagers
et nous sommes la troisième compagnie
internationale rêve la matière de
passage 1 qu air france est en bonne
santé à fond cette bonne santé parce que
si pour rester comparable aux autres
compagnies jeu mais concorde à part eh
bien nous avons un bénéfice de 255
millions de francs nous dégageons une
marge d'autofinancement de 825 millions
de francs qui représentent en valeur
environ 59% de mon investissement
ce qui veut dire que nous avons des
résultats financiers positifs
bénéficiaires contemple à ceux des
meilleurs complètement l'importance si
vous faites des bénéfices vous allez
pouvoir diminuer vos tarifs mais ces
bénéfices sont une bonne base de départ
avec bénéfices de cette année de cachet
pour en faire de 11 milliards qui vont
nous permettre évidemment de baisser
sensiblement les tarifs nous allons
baisser les tarifs parce qu'il faut
baisser parce que à la clientèle à
l'élite de la forte ned des affaires sur
laquelle ces essais créent-ils transport
aérien succède maintenant le transport
pense à nos amis nous allons baisser les
tarifs commencent en 1979 cette
opération mais nous le faisons
essentiellement nos fonds de nouveaux
produits qui soient moins chers nouveau
type de traitement au sol nouveau 4e en
vin nouveau type management nous avions
deux nouveaux produits qui sont rochelle
c'est un qui nous permettent dans la
comptabilité d'offrir des tarifs plus
bas